[Music]
that seems like a good moment to take
some questions
thank you very much I'd like to ask you
all I want it more towards my mouth yes
right I'd like to ask you what surprised
you and pleased you the most about how
your own thinking has moved on in the
recent past thank you and could we take
the one behind as well can I first start
off with a negative I find it a very
sort of navel-gazing debate I when I
read the when I came to this sort of it
I really love the idea of do African
conceptions of the self or Chinese
Maoist logic offer equally valid
insights and I was sort of hoping for a
discussion about more specifics to and
it says to interrogate the limits of
Western philosophy and do any of you
have any question is do any of you have
any experience of those we're dealt what
is the limit of Western philosophy and
what does for example African owest
thought have - or Chinese Maoist logic
or the African conception of the self
what specifically what are those ideas
and how do they relate to Western
philosophy and how do they differ do you
say lemme more specifics that would give
me some clarity about what the limits of
Western philosophy are this book is 15
years old so I'm not plugging it anymore
but and it would call Eastern philosophy
I actually tackle exactly the question
of the nature of logic in mohism and
Chinese an Indian Indian philosophy that
the problem is that it's it's quite
demanding I spent three years learning
classical Chinese and I've forgotten
most of it because the languages I work
in our Tamil Sanskrit practice Ali but
not Chinese classical Chinese but it's
DeForge that's why it's difficult for us
to get down to the into the weeds
because we're asking the larger
questions I think once you start asking
it in terms of what the limits of a
tradition are you
cannot give a global onset way you have
to go to every tradition that you're
dealing with asking where is it running
out so if some of the work I've been
doing is in terms of this historical in
a comparisons we're talking about is to
say that modern philosophy as it is has
developed in the West reacted in a
particular historical trajectory to
Descartes and the idea that we are made
up of you know body and mind and how to
overcome those divides there are other
traditions which for good or for L never
quite tackled it in that way they might
have made the analytic distinctions of
our body and mind and other kinds of
aspects of the human being but they read
the human being in a different way but
in order to say well what does that show
you know I've been writing out in a
three or four books and I can't even
pretend that I've begun to really
understand how to say what the problem
is all I can do is to act it through so
I think it's a little unfair for you to
expect us to be able to sort of say
let's get down into the weeds on this
particular question and then within by
the time we've even set the
preliminaries we are out of time but it
might be a good moment to pick short
events later today I can only think of
things I wrote 20 years ago I will be in
the ring at 4 p.m. talking about ideas
of consciousness and Indian philosophy
so I think that's a bit more than the
specificity thank you for looking for
and perhaps we can come back to the
other question we had about what
surprised you in terms of the
development of your own thinking what
what's in what surprised me most over
the last three years is how I was able
to to simplify the the logic of
conditionals the if-then statements in
in ways that depended on on showing that
certain kinds of complications
we're the result of taking
judgments that are psychologically
natural too much at face value when in
in fact they they're based on kind of
heuristics that kind of ways of thinking
that people rely on that that are that
work most of the time but are not a
hundred percent reliable and that to
realize that there are errors in the
data that had been blocking people from
adopting a much more straightforward
theories that but that isn't that was
I'm afraid I wasn't inspired by anything
particular in AI in a philosophical
tradition but actually more by inference
from developments in psychology to do
with the idea of heuristics that people
rely on in their thinking yeah I what
surprised me and actually displeased me
rather than pleased me was the fact that
I can't take anything anymore for
granted so I need to problematize
everything I see you're read or hear and
that I mean I'm no no nowhere near the
end of my thinking on this so hopefully
that would also change in a few years
but it that's the one thing that has led
to quite a lot of reflection and but yes
it's not often pleasing but it is
surprising that I'm so very often wrong
I don't even know when I'm wrong or
whether right or wrong exists you know
even now I'm kind of problematizing what
I'm saying and so yeah in I just want to
come back to your point about how you
expected something different um like I
said I'm not I haven't ever study
Chinese philosophy or African philosophy
I'm not philosopher but to me for me
what the limit of Western philosophy is
the fact that it refuses to recognize
its own limits the fact that it
continues to claim truth to everything
it says and the fact that it can be
exotic eyes or provincial eyes when
you're coming at it from a different
angle doesn't occur to itself
now again I'm homogenizing but it tends
to do that itself so that is to me the
limit and that's not a limit coming from
any other tradition it's coming from
within the tradition if you see what I
was saying yeah well what surprised me
is that after spending 25 years speaking
for myself as an Indian philosopher
in conversation of the West I've been
struck by how younger people are making
me think how much I'm stink against
myself as somebody who comes from a very
elite Indian tradition of thought and as
a man who assumes too many things so
it's learning to speak against myself
that has most surprised me and as most
necessarily surprised me did you take
some more questions um thank you
yeah first of all I wonder whether what
we we say or the the question said was a
prejudice perhaps against any other
philosophy unless its European American
or whatever whether that's partly based
on ignorance of Eastern philosophy for
example because perhaps they thought you
know Western philosophy is very secular
Eastern philosophy to them just look
like religion or spirituality and did
not respect it enough and the point you
you made about Western philosophy
doesn't perhaps know its limits
I think the you know the the the
definition of consciousness I know
you're going to talk about that at 4:00
p.m. but that's one area that that seems
to me there's I get a lot of arrogance
about you know where we go with
consciousness and what the the
definition may be anyway I don't know
what that was a question or it was a
question here thank you I was going to
ask about where the panelists think that
the obsession for generalizability comes
from and how useful is it thank you and
I think there's one question if you
could pass it back that'd be great thank
you thank you um I just I was interested
you were talking about rationalism and
mysticism being the sort of Indian
stereotyping practice in universities
and I've studied both Western philosophy
and in East in the BA - in India in
Indian University and
Indian philosophy in a Western
University and I feel like both is you
then try to rationalize what is a miss
more mystical way of thinking about the
world and also vice versa and then you
miss quite a lot of the the points and
and the values and I just wondered if
you think there's a fundamental
incompatibility between for example
conceptions of what is the truth so in
India truth is something eternal
unchanging means Brahman it means truth
is that and then maybe in Western
tradition truth is exactly this ability
to constantly update it and change it
empirically and I wondered if that or
something else you thought was
incompatible I I need to really come
back on that there is no such
distinction there is it would come as a
shock to agustin or Aquinas to be told
that they weren't committed to an
eternal truth and it would come as a
shock to the kerala school of astronomy
in the 12th and 13th century who are
developing a heliocentric theory of the
world that they were they there that
they weren't constantly expanding the
horizons of their investigation then
there are no such generalize abilities
the first thing about really having to
come to grips with different traditions
of thought is never to be contented with
a level of generalizability this there
is always internal contestation some
questions are asked in certain
traditions that are not asked in other
traditions that's perfectly true but
it's actually shocking how many
questions are asked by all kinds of
different traditions and I think it's
realizing how decentered is any one
tradition of thought that we haven't yet
grappled with it's a real genuine shock
when you read a text which has clearly
no historical connection with some other
quick text in some other part of the
world in some other language you're used
to and you confront this question
that keeps people like compacted lost
ones like me employed but that is
actually really important to not think
that there are simple contrasts this
question only obsession for
generalizability well I mean one
advantage of generalizations is that
they're extremely informative if they're
true and so if you can get them that
they're a good thing I I do think that
one thing that has happened is in
philosophy recently but it met much
earlier in the Natural Sciences is that
people have learned that there are
certain areas where you can't really
expect Exceptionalist generalizations I
mean maybe you can't actually expect
even very many of those even in biology
and what you have to look for are simple
models that as where I abstract away
from a lot of the the mess of the the
real world but still give you an insight
into some of those structures that are
in some messy form are operating and so
that's a that's a different kind of
understanding which i think is becoming
more accepted within analytic philosophy
i mean but what one thing i wanted to
say in answer to the questions was that
when we're talking about the limits of
the the Western tradition there's a
difference between the limits of where
it's got at any particular time and the
limits of it as an ongoing tradition
that you know persists over a long
periods because of I think you'd be hard
put to find any analytic philosopher who
thought that that analytic philosophy
had somehow got exclusive rights to the
truth that would be a crazy claim and I
mean there I think
almost everyone would agree that that
there are as there were good ideas that
we've not yet
and that are better than what we're
thinking at the moment I think I think
be be crazy to not to think that and I
think the the real question is whether a
tradition is open enough that it can can
accept improvements on its ideas which
are which are coming from the outside
and and I think it's it's not clear that
though that the analytic tradition can't
can't do that because you know I think
that the that this the stereotype that
it's only within the Western tradition
that that valuable philosophy happen
it's has been pretty much abandoned by
my most analytic philosophers I think
that what the ones who would stick to
that are pretty old old-fashioned and
marginalized well on the on the question
of whether there's been good ideas that
we haven't yet had they absolutely do
make space for that but what about the
ideas that we might have had had the
monopoly to philosophize not rested
within 0.01 percent of the world's
population and 1% at that time right
that's that is the that is why Western
philosophy needs to be exalted eyes and
prevent relized not because it hasn't
had it good ideas and not because it
doesn't say that good ideas might yet be
had but the fact that it doesn't
consider where it has come from and what
that means for lots of people around the
world yeah but I mean that is to some
extent crying over spilt milk and the
quest the question is how we're going to
get better ideas in the future we we
can't do much about failings in the past
but we but we can think about how to to
do better in the future we can also
acknowledge more emphatically that we
have had those feelings rather than
continuing to say we can only do better
in the future I don't think that's how
progress is made we need to say okay
we've been pretty crappy a lot of this
and so what can we do and where else can
we look and their archives there to
still explore yeah unfortunately we are
out of time thank you so much for coming
I think that's everything thank you so
much
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV